[Music]
have you spoken to James Harden yet no
you haven't
did you did you have you thought at all
about giving him a call or anything like
that is well what a tacit here
I mean well when it happened you know I
didn't really know he was really that
hurt until the day after right because
you know guys flop in the NBA and so you
don't really know I knew that if I was
to get some game throw a benefit of
Oklahoma if there was they gave me
suspended and possibly for the playoffs
yeah you know knowing that real play
time so I didn't know what was happening
then a couple days you didn't play so I
called some third parties you know and
they told me that he was I'm doing okay
so I'm sorry when you check in with
third parties to see but not with him
because I might have to play him in the
playoffs oh I don't want to really talk
to him but I did make sure he was okay
so you you want to maintain whatever you
want you want to maintain this edge the
hoch really okay I mean don't you think
I mean he's still gonna be stay clear of
your elbows even if you sent him flowers
you know it's a tricky thing I didn't
realize you have to take it that far
that you can't just call him up and say
I'm really sorry that happened and now
it's so competitive you know so I was
like I don't really want to I want to
make sure he's okay first so I made that
but to call him you know knowing that he
was gonna be okay I could not call him
right now because we have games to play
or well let's talk about that first of
all you're not playing right now you've
got a seven-game suspension what did you
think of that punishment that punishment
I had no I really had no thoughts on the
punishment but it was just all the
comments from like you get a guy like
not him exactly but a guy like Billy and
bear I said that was wrong he should've
never done that no when this guy clearly
in the 80s was like played exactly how I
play now you know I might get retro
player but it was a lot of guys I hope
I'm not gret role you know and I'm like
a lot of guys I'm making comments so you
thought there was people were being
hypocrite said there are the same stuff
yeah there's a lot of hypocrites you
know the regular media I was like okay
they can have their judgment because
that's what they do but then when you
get a player that you play with that she
was in the same locker room with that's
talking about children's he because he
has this new job so you giggle whatever
and he's talking about she was like come
on he was in the locker room when you
asked me to protect you
right so you get people that you know
for that know full effect behave the
same way that you know either did or was
you know he was a happy way I played the
game right and then they on TV and they
talking about me people that called me I
was like they big like a little brother
you know just family and used to see
them on TV like bashing me I was like
wow okay